المترجم: Shaimaa Alamoudi
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
في ساعة صفاء، وأنا جالسة مع ابنتي بعدما
انتهينا من رحلة إلى حديقة الحيوان
سألتها: ما هو أفضل حيوان أعجبك اليوم؟
اعتقدت أنها سوف تقول الحصان
أو الغزال أو الزرافة
فقاطعت حديثي بكل حماس قائلة: (The bat)
أي الخفاش أو الوطواط
سألتها: "هل هذا هو؟" وأجابتني: "نعم!"
ثم أكملت قائلة بكل ثقة: "إنه
لطيف جداً يا أمي!"
حسناً، إنني أتقبل وجهة نظر الأطفال
فأنا أم وأحترم وجهة نظر ابنتي
قالت لي: "حتى ملابسه جميلة جداً يا أمي!
هل يمكننا تربيته؟"
أجبتها: "لا. سوف ننهي الموضوع الآن"
في اليوم ذاته كنت أنجز عملي على حاسوبي
وكانت هي في الغرفة المجاورة
وفجأة سمعت صوت أقدامها وهي تجري نحوي
ثم فتحت الباب بكل قوتها وعاتبتها: "أين
الاستئذان؟" أجابتني: "لا يوجد لدي وقت"
قالت لي: "النملة!"
أجبتها: "ماذا حدث لها؟"
أجابتني: "سوف تقرصني!"
"حسناً، ماذا عن الوطواط الذي أردتي تربيته؟
أتخافي من نملة ولا تخافي من وطواط؟"
أجابتني: "لا، إن الوطواط لا يرى
ولكن النملة سوف تقرصني"
إنها مقتنعة بذلك
وبعد مناقشات طويلة
قلت لها إن النملة تمشي في حال سبيلها
وأن النملة ربما تكون خائفة منكِ من الأساس
ثم اقتنعت وفتحت الباب مغادرة الغرفة
وكأن خوفها لم يكن موجوداً
لحظات الخوف غالباً تكون تخيل لمواقف سيئة
أو تخيل لنتائج سيئة من غير خوض التجربة
وتوجد دراسات تقول: إن البشر هم أكثر
الكائنات خوفاً وذلك بسبب قدرتهم على التخيل
وخصوصاً تخيل الأفكار السيئة أو السلبية
فالخوف يمكن أن يكون تخيلاً
أو موقف سيىء حصل لك من قبل
وتربط به كل ما يحصل لك
أو معلومة قد سمعت بها من أشخاص آخرين
أود إخباركم بأنني اصطحبت ابنتي
إلى المستشفى قبل يومين
والممرضة حاولت أن تعطيها حقنة وقالت لها:
لا تخافي إنها مجرد قرصة نملة
نظرة إلي وقالت: "لا، لا!
إنها مجرد وطواط The bat The bat!"
ها نحن مجدداً نعود لموضوع الخفاش!
يبدو أننا سنتحدث عن الأمر مجدداً
في فترة من فترات حياتي، كنت
أعيش حالة خوف شديدة
بإمكانني أن أطلق عليها بحالة رعب
حقاً. كانت تمر أيام كنت لا أتحرك فيها
من من سريري بسبب شدة الخوف
الخوف من أشياء تدور في بالي
أو الخوف من مجهول
حاولت أن أقرأ كتب كثيرة، حاولت أن أقرأ
عن قصص نجاح آخرين قبلي
كنت أحاول البحث عن قصص خوف
مشابهة لحالتي من بينهم
كنت أحاول البحث عن تبرير
لقصة الخوف التي لازمتني
ولكنني لم أجد شيئاً
ولأننا نعيش حياة مليئة بالمظاهر والمثالية
وأن كل شخص فينا يجب أن يظهر كاملاً وقوياً
لم أكن قادرة على مشاركة قصتي مع أي شخص
كنت أحاول البحث عن أي شخص لألقي اللوم عليه
لأن اللوم هو طريقة لتفريغ الألم،
لم أعد قادرة على تحمل ذلك!
لكي لا أظهر ضعيفة أمام الجميع ولكي لا يأتي
يوم يقال عني إسراء الضعيفة أو الخائفة!
لا وألف لا! سأبقى دوماً الدكتورة إسراء
وسأحصل على شهادة الدكتوراة وأصبح قوية
كنت ألوم ذاتي في كل مرة أقف أمام
المرآة وألوم ذاتي إلى أن كرهتها
لابد أن أفارق الخوف الذي يكمن بداخلي
كان لدي مؤتمر في روما وذهبت وحاولت
الانسحاب من المؤتمر قبل أن أشارك بالحديث
"حديث" من دراسة أجريتها سابقاً
فهل أقرر الانسحاب أم أبادر بإلقاء الحديث
فقررت بالبدء بالحديث ولكن ليس لأنني قوية
بل بسبب خوفي من مشرفتي
خوف مقابل خوف! خوف مؤقت ولا خوف دائم
وبدأت بالحديث، والخوف اختفى بعد لحظات
واستمتعت بكل لحظة
والسبب أنه كان مجالي
ولم أحظى بتجربة سيئة سابقاً
فتحدثت حتى وصلت إلى فقرة الأسئلة
ثم جاوبت حتى انتهينا
بعدها، اجتمعت مع زملائي الدكاترة وناقشنا
الأفكار التي عرضت في المؤتمر
أثناء نقاشنا، كنا نتحدث عن طرق موت الخلايا
يوجد أكثر من طريقة ولكنني كنا نناقش طريقة
واحدة فقط
وأننا عندما نرفع كميات المخدر وما إلى ذلك،
فإن التوتر يرتفع في تلك الخلايا
يزيد التوتر ثم ترتفع بعض المؤشرات العصبية
إلى أن تموت تلك الخلايا
في هذه النقطة، شرد ذهني
ثم ابتعدت عنهم قليلاً
"النواقل العصبية"
مصطلح نسمعها بشكل يومي، في المعمل
أو في نقاشاتنا مع زملائي الدكاترة
لماذا لم أفكر بها مسبقاً؟
المؤشرات العصبية والنواقل العصبية هي مشاعر
أو هرمون سعادة أو زيادة في الخوف أو النوم
أو خمول أو فرح.
هي المشاعر التي كنت أشعر بها في الغالب
الخوف ليس ضعفاً إنما هو دليل
على أن المخ يعمل بطريقة سليمة
وأنك إنسان على قيد الحياة
بل كل مافي الأمر هو طريقتك بالتفسير
هل ستتعمق في تفسير تلك الأمور أم
أنك سوف تترجمها على أنها مؤشرات
في بعض الأحيان، سوف يرسل المخ إليك
بعض الرسائل التي تتطلب منك سماعها
ولكن لا تصدق أغلبها
توجد دراسات تقول بأن المخ سوف يرسل إليك
إشارة بالتعب بعد 40٪ فقط من جهدك
يجب عليك سماع تلك الرسائل
لكن عليك المضي قدماً
سوف تأتينا لاحقاً.. الأكيد أن المنظمين
قد شعروا بها، مشاعر بالتعب أو النعاس
ولكن مضوا قدماً ووصلوا إلى ما هم عليه الآن
وتغلبوا على ذاتهم من المؤشر الأول ثم غابوا
المشاعر ليست ضعف
وعدت نفسي بأن أتغلب على هذا الأمر
وأخرج من هذه القوقعة التي أنا بها
ولفعل هذا الأمر كان يجب علي طلب المساعدة
من أناس مختصين
كان لابد علي من التحدث إلى أناس متخصصين
في هذا المجال
وغادرت ...
لا يمكنكم تصور مدى الخوف الذي يكمن بداخلي
عندما أقول "أنا خائفة"
خائفة من ماذا؟ لا أعلم
أصبحت خائفة من الخوف ذاته
هيمن علي الخوف بالكامل
وأنا السبب في ذلك
بل أفكاري هيا السبب
بدأت أهدىء من روعي وانتهت مرحلة الخوف
ولكن ذلك لا يعني
بأنني أصبحت لا أخاف أبداً، حتماً لا!
وما يؤكد كلامي هو أنني سأقوم بتربية الخفاش
أي أتمنى أن لا أربيه!
سأقرر ذلك حالما أعود إلى المنزل
أي أحد، أي أحد يشعر بمشاعر الخوف،
أي أحد يشعر بمشاعر التخبط، فأنت لست بمفردك
لا تستسلم لمشاعرك، لا تستسلم
للنواقل العصبية عندما تأثر على دماغك
لا! بل قف ولا تبررها
فإنك ستشعر بها وهذا أمر طبيعي
ولا تبحث عن هذه المواقف في قصص
حياة الأشخاص الناجحين
بل إنهم سيتحدثون عن العواقب التي مروا بها
وليس عن مشاعرهم نحوها
لأن البعض منهم لا يريدون بأن يقال عنهم:
أنا قرأت عن هذا الشخص "الخائف"
لا! بل إنك قرأت عن هذا الشخص بأنه
استطاع أن يتغلب عن العقبات الملموسة فقط
والعقبات الأخرى لم يذكرها على الإطلاق
لأنه كان قوياً دائما ولم يخف قط
ليس صحيحاًاً
هناك أشخاص تخاف لكن لا يوجد من يعترف بذلك
أحب ذاتك، قدّرها، احترمها
احترم المشاعر التي تشعر بها
عامل عقلك وكأنك تعامل طفل يبلغ من العمر
خمس سنوات
سوف يحب أمور غريبة وسيخاف من أمور تافهة
لا تقارن ذاتك بغيرك،
ولا تهتم بردة فعل الآخرين
عندما تعيش التجربة للمرة الأولى،
فإنك ربما لن تستمتع بها ولكن،
ستستمتع بها في المرة القادمة بالتأكيد
ستقوى من ذاتك عند كل مرة تعيد تكرار
تلك التجربة مجدداً
ولا تقارن ذاتك أو ردات فعلك بالآخرين
ربما لن يخافوا من الوطواط،
ولكن ربما سيخافون من النملة
ستصبح أقوى في كل مرة تعيد تلك التجربة
مراراً وتكراراً
دون وحدد الأمور التي تريد تحقيقها
قائمة الأشياء التي تود إنجازها من أهداف
وأولويات والأمور التي تود تحقيقها
واكتب لعقلك في كل مرة أنجزت هدف ما
ماهي الأمور التي حققها
"Done List" وهي المهمة!
بل حتى أهم من "To-Do List"
لكي يشعر هو بالإنجاز في كل مرة استطاع
العمل والإنجاز وشعر بالتعب بها
يوجد أمر ملموس يصل إليه
لن ينتهي الخوف بالتمني أبداً
يوماً ما تمنيت أن يكون هناك "زر اختصار"
أتمنى لو أغادر فجأة، أتمنى أن أرجع وأكون
إسراء القديمة بمجرد ضغطي لهذا الزر
كنت أتمنى أن ترجع إسراء القديمة بالفعل
لكن، الآن أنا أقوى بكثير من إسراء القديمة
لن ينتهي الأمر هذا بنقرة زر،
ولن ينتهي بالتمني أيضاً
ولكن سوف ينتهي حتماً
عندما تعمل على تحقيق ذلك
عندما تعمل سوف يختفي وستتجاوز تلك المرحلة
اسأل ذاتك، ما الذي يمكن سيحدث لو أنني
واجهت وتجاوزت مرحلة الخوف تلك
ما هو أسوأ أمر يمكن أن يحدث؟
وما هي الأمور الجميلة التي سوف تحدث بعدها؟
استخدم الخوف كقوس يستطيع إرجاعك لحظة
ولكنه سوف يطلقك سريعاً نحو الهدف
صوب ذلك القوس إلى الهدف الذي تود تحقيقه
وإياك أن تصوبه إلى ذاتك،
لأنه سيقتل طموحاتك وبعدها يقتلك أنت!
وشكراً